[Music]
thank you for coming to this event
um i'm going to be talking about my new
book
the pattern seekers
this
explores a big question
is there a link between autism
and the capacity for invention
and what i hope to do is lay out the
evidence
that shows some links but before i do
that
let's turn to a related question
uh when did invention begin
so what's clear is that our hominid
ancestors could use simple stone tools
so in that sense we could say they could
invent for example
homo habilis
and homo erectus who both lived about
two million years ago
could use stone axes and stone hammers
and so could the neanderthals who lived
as recently as 40 000 years ago
but despite small changes in the design
of their tools as you can see
for millions of years there was very
little evidence
for what i call generative invention
that's to say the ability to invent in
multiple ways
not just um as a one-off
and if we look at
non-human
species
alive today
a lot of animals can use simple stone
tools
so the question is you know can they
invent
chimpanzees for example can use a rock
as a hammer to crack a nut
and you can see here
that crows can drop a stone into
water to raise the water level to be
able to reach a worm
uh both intelligent behavior
uh but i think that the behavior of
other animals
and indeed of our hominid ancestors can
be parsimoniously explained as the
result of associative learning
forming an association between two
things a and b
but this doesn't
show doesn't lead to or show any sign of
generative invention
but then suddenly
seventy thousand to a hundred thousand
years ago
when homo sapiens was on the scene
the rate of invention suddenly takes off
as you can see in this uh schematic
timeline and generative invention has
been unstoppable ever since
what we see suddenly is the capacity for
generative invention
not just inventing once but generating
non-stop
and i argue that this is because a
cognitive revolution
had occurred in the human brain
so what was this cognitive revolution
well i argue that there were two new
circuits in the human brain and the
first of these is what i call the
systemizing mechanism
so this allowed humans to look for
special patterns in the world
that i call if and then patterns
and these are the basis of of any system
that if i take something and i do
something to it then i get a particular
outcome
and the systemizing mechanism allowed us
to analyze the world to find such
patterns and then to confirm if they
hold true
and to do this we repeat our
observations over and over again
and once they're confirmed
we can then vary the pattern
by experimenting either with the if or
the and and i'll show you some examples
of this in a second
but when we produce a new if and then
pattern
that's what i'm calling uh
an invention
and i borrow this terminology from the
19th century logician
george bull who you can see
in this cartoon illustration
uh who analyzed the structure of of
human thought
so um we can infer the existence
of the systemizing mechanism in the
modern human brain because 75 000 years
ago we see the first jewelry
and if we try and imagine what was going
on in the mind of the inventor of this
complex
tool
he or she might have thought if i make a
hole in each shell
and thread a string through each hole
then the shells will form a necklace
so if and then reasoning as long ago 75
000 years ago
and 71 000 years ago we see the first
bow and arrow
again the same if and then algorithm
is evident that if i attach an arrow to
a stretchy fiber and release the tension
in the fiber then the arrow will fly
and
40 000 years ago we see
the earliest musical instrument that's
ever been found a flute made from a
hollow bone
again imagine the reasoning in the
ancestor who made this that if i blow
down the hollow bone and cover one hole
then i make a specific sound
but if i blow down the hollow bone and
cover two holes then i make a different
sound so our ancestor had invented a
complex tool a musical instrument and a
system of sounds that we call music
and
invention didn't stop there obviously
forty thousand years ago we see
uh cave paintings
twenty five 000 years ago we see these
remarkable sculptures
but by 12 000 years ago
we see the invention of agriculture and
again think about this if and then
reasoning that if i take a tomato seed
and plant it in moist soil then i get a
tomato plant
and of course the invention of
agriculture transformed our diet our
health style our health and our
lifestyles
and of course fast forward to 2021 we
are still
inventing unstoppably today
a recent example is the invention of the
vaccine
if i take the genes for covid's spike
protein
and put them into a harmless virus then
i have a vaccine against covid as just
one example but let's go back
75 000 years ago
because the systemizing mechanism
explains how we could invent how we
could make the first jewelry
but the empathy circuit
explains why we made it
we wear jewelry because we can imagine
what someone else might think or feel
we might imagine that they are thinking
that if we wear jewelry it makes us more
beautiful
it makes us look like we're of higher
status
or we might make jewelry as a gift to
give as a gift because we could imagine
that the other person
might feel happy
and the evolution of the empathy circuit
allowed a whole raft of complex social
interactions
including deception
and referential communication
but let's go back to our big question
is there a link between
autism and invention
anecdotally
there's uh lots of stories
about inventors
who have a high level of autistic traits
so this is thomas edison who famously
invented the first electric light bulb
but he was inventing non-stop
as a teenager he was obsessed with morse
code
a system of patterns
and he even named his children dot and
dash
and his wife moved the mattress into his
workshop so that he he could carry on
inventing and experimenting day and
night
and
here is glenn gould the pianist
again
an inventor of musical patterns
but who showed a lot of
autistic traits by the way we would
think about them today
for example he always had to have the
same chair at exactly the same height
in every concert
and after every concert always went to
the same restaurant and sat at the same
table and ordered exactly the same food
at exactly the same time at two o'clock
in the morning
so a lot of patterns of autistic traits
equally anecdotally
we know that a lot of autistic people
are very good at pattern recognition
have a talent in pattern recognition and
understanding systems this is max park
who is autistic
and despite his social difficulties he's
the number one world champion in the
rubik's cube which is a system of visual
patterns
this is derek paravicini who is autistic
congenitally blind and has learning
difficulties
but who can play any song
on the piano after hearing it just once
and this is daniel tamet
who is autistic
and has something called synesthesia or
a mixing of the senses
and he is the european champion for
memorizing the number pi
to 22
400 decimal places so he is fascinated
by systems of numbers
but anecdotes
are not
evidence
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas